foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is
scp-1425 object class safe
special containment procedures a single
copy of scp-1425 is to be kept in a
double locked archive in storage site
40. access to the document is to be
completely restricted barring Express
written permission of at least two of
the following officials the site
director the Eid Chief the CMA head or
o5 Personnel a second copy is contained
in an undisclosed location under
procedures divulged only to o5 council
members all forms of printed and
televised media available throughout the
United States are to be monitored for
the appearance of keyword words and key
symbols from the list provided in CMA
document 1425a and he located additional
copies of scp-1425 are to be turned over
to CMA custody for destruction in the
event that a second
scp-1425 event begins to manifest
contact an official listed above
immediately to initiate protocol of
ficus
description
scp-1425 is a hardcover book measuring
20 by 35 by 5 centimeters and published
in 2005 by the company books now defunct
see operation Stargazer files the front
cover Bears the title star signals the
back cover has the following description
did you know that some stars in the sky
are dead but we still see their ancient
image with the best-selling novel star
signals sold in four countries and
translated into hundreds of languages
you too can tune into the celestial
frequencies and then become like the
stars
when a subject reads the full text of
scp-1425 the book exerts a mild reality
warping effect influenced by the
subject's desires which in turn are
influenced by scp-1425 see below when a
sufficiently large number of subjects
are exposed to this effect further
complications arise in terms of mental
health and the Integrity of space-time
see event log 1425-05
the document is a non-fiction book of
the self-help genre advertised as a
manual which teaches the use of the
five-step star signal method to achieve
the reader's dreams and Ambitions the
method itself is a program of
visualization reinforced through mantras
and positive affirmations unlike nearly
all books of the self-help genre
scp-1425 is directly efficacious in
assisting the subject in achieving
personal goals the book has no content
regarding practical measures to achieve
goals instead it speaks entirely on
these star focuses and other wishful
thinking rituals these exercises when
conducted properly demonstrably
influence reality beginning with a
direct influence on the appearance of
the star used in the exercise a reader
who expresses a wish to win the lottery
will receive a winning ticket within the
next week any reader whose goal is a new
car will find themselves driving it the
next week the amount of work invested
into achieving the goal outside of
Performing the prescribed rituals as
only a supplementary effect a subject
who makes no special effort to pursue
the focused desire still succeeds at a
rate documented at roughly 80 percent
however if the instructions for reading
order and frequency are not followed
correctly the anomalous effect is either
greatly diminished or Falls entirely
in early chapters these exercises are
focused on two things the exact goals
that the reader has in mind and the
concentration on certain stars in the
sky this activity is connected to the
titular star signals
scp-1425 claims that the light emitted
by stars carries a phenomenological
frequency which is connected to each
star and which is connected to the
phenomenological frequency of each
human's mind each of the book's 10
chapters ends with a star focused ritual
this is a meditation performed each
night with the central Focus being a
Celestial body the celestial body used
is determined by a calendar given in the
prologue this ensures that all readers
at any given time are focusing on the
same place no matter which section of
the book they are reading the 10th
chapter is an exception see document
1425 a
throughout its Pages
scp-1425 contains verbal devices
intended to influence the mind of the
reader during exercises these include
the combination of memetic triggers and
neuro-linguistic programming to make
this subject receptive to the ideas
presented in the text and to optimize
the results of its anomalous effect once
the core ideas of the book have been
introduced and worked upon visualization
exercises begin to include concentration
on other Concepts including political
and philosophical messages the latter
chapters of the book serve to alter the
thoughts and desires of the user to
conform to a standard that would remain
consistent across readers of the text
approximately 60 percent of readers who
have read the entirety of scp-1425
exhibit a mental condition called Ojai
syndrome see event log
scp-1425 2005.
scp-1425 is believed to have been
written and published by operatives of
the fifth Church an influential cult
whose membership consists largely of
celebrities including actors musicians
authors television hosts and other
personalities at that time the list of
confirmed fifthists numbered with the
list of suspected cultists counting in
excess of
these connections were utilized by the
fifthist fellowship in the form of
celebrity endorsements and widespread
media coverage used to make scp-1425
quickly and exceptionally popular due to
these measures as well as substantial
Word of Mouth advertising star signals
became a national bestseller within two
weeks of publication and held this
position until the book was virtually
purged from public knowledge by the SCP
Foundation using protocol othicus
document 1425 a
scp-1425 excerpt
the following passages are taken
directly from the text of scp-1425 these
excerpts have been selected to minimize
exposure to Cognito hazardous memetic
triggers and other textual anomalies
chapter 2 Section 3 the whole you exist
around
do you feel a void in your life everyone
does whether they know it or not think
about it you can feel it inside you
right now a heavy emptiness in the
middle of your chest it's a reflection
of the one in your existence like
particles in quantum entanglement but do
you remember how we talked about quantum
entanglement not yet
yes you do yes you feel the emptiness
this is good it's a blank slot waiting
for you to fill it up with your deepest
desire until your deepest desire is
pushing up into your throat you will gag
on your need and until you do it is a
resonation space for you to build your
will like organ music in a cathedral
hear the music now this is not a
metaphor if your will is strong enough
there will be music now remember now
that nothing in this book is a metaphor
chapter 3 taking effects Section 5 you
are in time
star Focus
find your night spot and begin to focus
on your star prologue Section 3 star
Focus calendar April
Epsilon sagittari if you can't find it
in your star chart it's the base of the
Hunter's bow and the brightest star in
the constellation as you stare up into
it use your mind clearing word your
meditation is now is your time here is
our space we take your star we hold your
bonds repay your debt
don't worry about memorization anytime
you use your mind clearing word you'll
remember them even if you only read them
once if you do it right your star will
disappear you'll feel it resonating with
the others in your Void
chapter 5 end of act 1 section 4 2 days
if you have read this book correctly and
you have tomorrow is the start of the
weekend
savor it the five-day Work Week is an
artifact of Your World you'll find out
all about that on Monday during the next
two days put this book down don't pick
it up yes this means two days without
your star exercises yes this means that
for two days your will is not going to
be with you don't even think about it
after the end of this sentence your will
is being used for your good
chapter 6 the fifth world section 2 the
fifth reason
as if this is the key to making your
desires real what does that mean it
doesn't mean anything you can't be
anyone other than yourself if you as
someone else you would still be you and
you would be someone who is someone else
there is no getting out from under
existence because you can't be anyone
else it stands to reason that if you
want to change in your reality it is the
world that must change to suit you you
must mold your phenomenological
landscape into one where all your goals
are achieved
now imagine that place where your
desires are made real has a name it is
called the fifth world the fifth world
is the cosmos twisted around you into
the shape you will wish for it has never
been but you can make it so if the
current world is like a tight collared
suit then the fifth world is like a
flowing robe that allows complete
freedom of movement you will never truly
move before you move in the fifth world
you'll feel like a square on a piece of
paper who's only just allow about up and
down
chapter 9 do not look away from the book
Section 3 Here and Now
some helpful advice that will save you
in your coming weeks
mirrors are for other people
sit in a dark room by yourself for at
least an hour per day move around as
much as you're mate too
if you feel yourself developing a soul
go outside immediately and follow the
direction of the smoke until you meet
them
always listen for the sound of Sloan of
terwall Palau milgenday
love the archons when you hate them they
see you
chapter 10 you cannot wake up section
one
pillow
remaining sample expunged
event log 1425-05.
level 2 clearance or higher only
the following events occurred between
the publication date of scp-1425 April
2nd 2005 and the official end date of
event 1425. May 11 2005.
day one Monday 4 22.
the second print run of scp-1425 is
completed simultaneously at three
locations the Publishing House main
printing facility then located in Texas
a smaller facility located in Maine and
a third branch in England the first two
factories ship
scp-1425 do bookstores Across America
the third is distributed throughout the
British Isles the first print run was
according to recovered documentation a
private distribution amongst members of
the fifth Church to be passed to friends
and family
day eight Monday 4 29.
television host daytime talk show airs
its monthly reading Circle special the
entirety of the episode is devoted to
the promotion of scp-1425 the host
claims that star signals rocked her
world and that you'll see and feel the
changes almost instantly at the 31
minute Mark her guest Hugh Laurie jokes
that the book's advice may be
responsible for the host's success he
adds I hope nobody hates you the host
looks at a copy of scp-1425 in her hands
for four seconds before remarking it's
finding the holes this line is muted in
its entirety in the west coast fate but
appears uncensored in the live airing
stirring much controversy on the subject
of obscenity in television sales of
scp-1425 grow to over 50 times their
current rate over the coming week
day 12 Friday 5 3.
reports of mental illnesses begin to
increase in the southwestern United
States in Ojai California the boyar
family a 45 year old father 50-year-old
mother and 24 year old daughter are
admitted to an Ojai mental institution
following what appears to be three
simultaneous episodes of glossolalia and
violent and delusional Behavior the trio
was located in a strait several miles
from their home conversing loudly to
each other about their surroundings
Witnesses report overhearing the remarks
I love how the buildings don't line up
anymore and once I get conversant I'll
fix your tongues if I have to when a
bystander approaches the Boyers the
mother remarks that it's not supposed to
be out and the father begins to assault
the bystander with a pocket knife local
law enforcement is notified and when
officers arrive the 24 year old is as a
witness reports shouting nonsense
speculated to be similar to the text of
chapter 10 of scp-1425 to the bystander
who is being held down by the father and
mother the bystander is being made to
repeat these utterances when the
bystander makes an error in punctuation
the father carves into four long
existing Cuts made on the bystander's
face forming a square the three are
arrested and the bystander is admitted
to a local hospital for bruises and
severe lacerations
day 13 Saturday 5 4.
Foundation agents investigate the case
of the boyars and determine a possible
link between their outbursts and the
book titled star signals the boyar's
copy is confiscated for examination as
well as a new copy from a local
bookstore
researchers note that although star
signals has been available in the market
for nearly two weeks no critical reviews
or other analytical reports have been
published in newspapers nor on
television and roughly 80 percent of
online reviews have been deleted by the
website's owners this is later
determined to be an intentional action
on the part of the fifth Church part of
scp-1425's mind-altering effect is a
reluctance to openly discuss the actual
text of the publication even in
Celebrity endorsements
day 14 Sunday 5 5.
Foundation researchers studying star
signals confirmed the connection with
the recent upswing in mental hospital
attendance and arrests for irrational
Behavior most of those affected by the
syndrome are non-violent but all
identified cases contain the common
threads of peculiarly delusional
statements and speaking in an
indecipherable consonant heavy language
following in-depth analysis star signals
is classified as an anomalous Cognito
Hazard and designated
scp-1425 researchers alert the site
director as due to the SCP designation
of the text star signals the foundation
is experiencing a massive containment
Bridge
Foundation agents determined that based
on the air date of the reading Circle
episode of
television show
scp-1425's strict instructions on how it
is to be read beginning on Monday and
continuing for one chapter per day each
weekday for two weeks and the
manifestation of the anomalous effect
when the subject completes the full text
of scp-1425 the spike in symptoms
predicted by researchers will be
experienced on day 19. Friday May 10th
when readers who purchased the book on
the same day as the episode aired will
have completed the program
day 15 Monday 5-6
Foundation researchers in storage site
40 and Foundation agents at o5
headquarters in conjunction with
Foundation subdivisions the CMA
communication moderation agency and Eid
lay out a process for retrieving
containing and destroying as many
instances of scp-1425 is possible this
plan is designated protocol of fica's
steps taken immediately upon
implementation include
the publishing company is determined to
be a front for the fifth church and is
seized mobile task force Theta 11
Wranglers mobile task force gamma 4
money lenders and mobile task force
Lambda 21 cave dwellers are sent to
Texas Maine and England printing
facilities respectively all mobile task
forces are met with armed resistance and
engage with no friendly casualties
publication of scp-1421 is ended the
Publishers headquarters in California is
commandeered by a mobile task force 5-1
hostile takeover
an international recall is issued
through the use of Eid intelligence
Foundation agents circumvent the star
signals media blackout the press release
claims that the 11th chapter has been
omitted and that the 10th chapter has
been severely misprinted consumers are
given an incentive of a 25 voucher for
returning a copy of star signals
bookstores in America and England pull
their stock of scp-1425 for recall
the CMA monitors all national broadcasts
especially Network television for
anomalies related to
scp-1425 any such anomalies are to be
removed from broadcast through one of
several classified means
further action redacted
Additionally the first broadcast to be
intercepted through the use of protocol
of Ficus is during the daytime talk show
which features further promotion of
scp-1425 television host conducts an
interview with musician Beck at the
18-minute Mark the following incident
occurs
I hear you're very spiritual does it
influence your work yum it has to be
it's an influence on everything no
matter what I'm doing I try to keep
grounded that's emphasis on try to
there's a reason why it's it's uh called
practicing
spirituality you can never get good at
interrupting off screen can I just say
something the camera angle changes to a
close-up of space the host is staring
directly at the viewer you have to keep
calm
take a good deep breath
remember what the man said
Stars may die in threes but worlds die
in fives like insects injected with
maggots turning back to their guests
what were we talking about I don't
actually
remember you were talking about
celebrities yes I wanted to ask you know
died recently audience size sadly how's
it affected you
why don't I just say I think we'll stay
together audience cheers
the network is contacted by the
foundation and releases a public
statement that
is suffering from exhaustion and will
not be taping episodes in the following
week
is unable to be located for
entertainment
day 16 Tuesday 5 7.
since day 12 several dozen instances of
behavior similar to that of the boyar
family have been publicly reported the
mental illnesses dubbed Ojai syndrome in
television online and newspaper reports
and is to the general public entirely
unexplained Foundation testing on
subjects with the disorder has
demonstrated that a moderate dosage of
Class B amnestics is effective in
treating Ojai syndrome
broadcast intercepted by protocol of
Ficus 24-hour News Network an interview
between pundit
Parliament member began to cover events
which have never actually occurred the
MP for example considers the
consequences of a revolution in India in
1921 which he describes as shorter than
the Boston Massacre and ten times as
bloody audio recording follows
you know there are some people out there
who believe that if we wish something
didn't happen hard enough if it didn't
really happen I'm that right you know
well it's about quantity isn't it they
don't have to wish very hard but there
have to be a lot of the suckers it works
both ways you know
I find my own assistance unable to tell
me with a Gandhi of a committed public
suicide they honestly can't remember and
this isn't a matter of poor education in
University they were completely aware of
what had happened at the time ask them
about the machine elf sometime see how
many they can name at this point
goodness know they couldn't name a demo
that killed their own parents
hey why isn't your prime minister been
eaten yet give it a week hell give it
until Friday always great to see you
come back on if you can be outside next
week
thanks I'll take you up on that
anyway let's get back to the
interviewer's co-host is visibly
uncomfortable are we still on
day 17 Wednesday 5 8.
the recall is a moderate success
approximately 200 000 instances of
scp-1425 are confiscated and destroyed
by incineration an additional claim is
released to the Press indicating that
copies of star signals may have been
contaminated with ricin due to an attack
by domestic terrorists
various subjects who are afflicted with
Ojai syndrome are gathered by the
foundation and administered a series of
doses of Class B amnestics they are
returned to their mental faculties with
a sharp decline in symptoms the
foundation is granted emergency position
by the CDC and the NHS to treat Ojai
syndrome sufferers following a partially
fabricated presentation in which the
illness is presented as a condition
caused by a parasitic organism several
International cases are reported but
these are highly sparse and too
difficult to track
broadcast intercepted by protocol of
ficus North Carolina Public Access
Children's Program Pepe's backyard the
host a man in rabbit makeup referred to
as Pepe is speaking to several children
sitting on the set in a semi-circle
[Music]
all right kids
[Music]
kids teaches as well as he learns and
dishes it out as well as he takes it
because nobody hates off screen we don't
have any guests today Pepe then what are
we doing this episode is about being
creative
really sorry I got distracted I guess
kids pay close attention I'll teach you
how to make candles out of whoever you
find lying around
I have what
no stop being such a square cut
day 18 Thursday 5 9.
the rate at which instances of scp-1425
are confiscated begins to slow most
remaining readers are under the
influence of scp-1425 suggestion and
have no intention of relinquishing their
copy of the text in metropolitan areas
across Coastal America and major cities
in Britain as well as towns and the
Southern United States near Foundation
facilities and known to be areas where
the sect known as Southern fifthism has
taken root agents travel from door to
door in hazardous material suits using
the cover story that copies of star
signals have been contaminated by rice
and powder a small percentage of
occupied houses contain subjects
moderately affected by scp-1425 who
resisted agents who resorted to physical
coercion in confiscating
scp-1425 during the personal
intervention operations of days 18 and
19 nine subjects under the effects of
scp-1420 25 are terminated in America
due to their impeding the continued
execution of protocol of Ficus and only
four such incidents occur in England in
Britain where the fifth Church's
influence seems to be much weaker
scp-1425 is believed to be almost
entirely eradicated
in an incident quickly concealed by the
United States government three Senators
attempted to report President George W
bush to the FBI in the official report
the legislative officials claimed that
President Bush's impostering because he
was executed months ago the Senators go
on to suggest a live execution on
broadcast television which will
definitely tank they unanimously insist
that it be hosted by comedian Dana
Carvey who could have his fingers force
fed to him as an opening sketch
broadcast intercepted by protocol of
ficus
the May 9th episode of popular talent
show American Idol is removed from Air
in its entirety after approximately 10
minutes of advertisements and
preliminary introduction the host Ryan
Seacrest stops when introducing the
first contestant audio recording follows
now let's
you probably remember our first singer
from last week when he made his version
of Paula referring to judge Paula Abdul
are you crying the judge's hand is over
her face and her voice is shaking I just
feel kinda sick ladies and gentlemen
Paul has had a long week audience laughs
you think it might be happening I think
you need to go
on with the show
Simon Cowell another Talent judge on the
program is sitting to call his left no
no we want to hear about this I think
it's coming up I just want to let
everyone know right now Paula can't see
us her vision is obscured by a world
that's being slaughtered like a cat
fresh cavities open in the earth like
sucking moths because it doesn't want to
wait for the flesh to cool their teeth
melt as they're cremated alive the host
looks toward the camera come on Jim
focus in on her pain
we might need it for later several
members of the audience laugh
all our Apple sits up as her neck
wrenches back as if by spasm
your mouse opens wide in a thick black
smoke begins to spew forth and there you
go Randy referring to the third panelist
on the far left Randy Jackson take a
deep breath you might be able to join
her in hell I'll do that [ __ ] in my own
home Ryan just take off the mask we
aren't even on the air right now this
with his left hand this is real
they'll have to rip it off me
you're alive with the words right I'm
alive with the words this is followed by
two minutes of Silence from the host
judges and audience after that Seacrest
Cowell and Jacksonville emitting smoke
upward from their mouths into the studio
at no point is the audience audibly
react this continues until the end of
the episode with the camera angle
focused on the judges occasionally
interspersed with a close-up of an
audience member Frozen in shock or
weeping silently
day 19 Friday 5 10.
as efforts made to enforce the protocol
of fica's reach in their pink Behavior
consistent with descriptions of Ojai
syndrome reaches its Zenith Foundation
patrols find Ojai syndrome sufferers in
the streets claiming to be following
smoke as outlined in the text see
document 1425a the event is presented to
the news as the result of a foodborne
parasite and individuals are instructed
to report to local hospitals where the
foundation provides amnestic therapy a
total of 400 individuals in the U.S and
300 individuals in Britain are located
and treated with class B amnestics note
this indicates that efforts prior to 5
1005 in Britain were much less
sufficient than previously thought
further inquiry is recommended
broadcast intercepted by protocol of
ficus
on the daytime talk show host hosts an
episode alone the studio is dark and
apparently contains no audience the host
carries a lit candle for illumination
two cameras are used though it is
unknown how they are being operated one
is set up to capture and the seat across
from her one is directly in front of her
greets the audience her face slipped
from below her face is flushed and bears
smeared makeup indicating recent crying
she explains in a flat voice that the
lights in the studio have been shut off
an act to which she finds preferable as
she does not want to see what's in here
she conducts an interview which she
claims is with comedian Dave Chappelle
however he is never seen nor is the
chair he is claimed to be seated in and
no response to her questions is audible
she reacts as if hearing responses
however sometimes breaking into laughter
or wiping tears from her eyes subjects
range from the mundane the latest season
of the sketch comedy series Chappelle's
Show two more anomalous topics such as
astronomical events related to the text
of scp-1425 including
at the 20-minute Mark is speaking
directly into the camera when she is
into erupted by a black gloved hand
grabbing her mouth from behind a muffled
scream is heard from the host as she is
pulled backwards from her seat and the
candle's light is snuffed below the
frame Foundation agents who were
deployed to the studio arrive presuming
that statement that their show was
airing live were accurate six minutes
after this event the studio is
completely empty with no sign of recent
activity
day 20 Saturday 5 11 and onward
fewer than copies of scp-1425 are
believed to be extant in society not
counting any which remain directly in
the hands of the fifth church over the
next week a further 200 sufferers of
Ojai syndrome are cured and released and
24 celebrities offer apologies for
erratic Behavior displayed during the
scp-1425 event note that all
personalities involved in television
incidents claim to have no memory of the
events including any crew and audience
members present continued monitoring of
subjects treated for oil syndrome
indicates no apparent long-term effects
protocol of Ficus enters its final stage
the first part involves continuous
International surveillance for scp-1425
related incidents and since then only
one broadcast has been interrupted due
to the protocol a British celebrity news
program which aired footage of Prince
Harry
consistent with the 510 broadcast the
second part consists of the systematic
elimination of all records of star
signals Ojai syndrome and any related
incidents from public record and public
history all film and print records of
scp-1425 related events have been
eradicated on class dynastic program
1425 let
measures to neutralize the fifth church
as a threat to the goals of the
foundation are put into the planning
phase in a mission which would later be
designated as operation Stargazer see
Stargazer documentation
addendo 1425 a
level 3 clearance or higher only
if you're learning of event 1425 for the
first time the details reported here may
come as a surprise it's a hard notion to
swallow even for a foundation researcher
that we could cut three weeks of Western
culture from memory on history but
doubts is Justified
the party line is not the SCP Foundation
is all capable and all prepared but if
you're reading this you've earned a
little Candor the incontrovertible fact
of event 1425 is that we got lucky
circumstances won the day for a number
of reasons those reasons are not listed
in the event lock not all the missions
leave helpful little notes behind
one the situation was much more worse
than we realized in case you haven't
been here long enough to learn to read
between the lines this wasn't just a
containment Bridge one reality warping
mimetically active fantasy book outside
of custody is a containment Bridge a
million such objects in uncontained
circulation well the official term is
impending CK class reality restructuring
event and they would have gotten away
with it too as I'm about to explain
2. the cleanup in England was a fiasco
the eradication of scp-1425 from Great
Britain failed substantially and we
didn't realize until it was nearly too
late on Sunday a day after the
officially marked end date of the event
there was an existential shift during
the Royal Parade When thousands of loyal
subjects were together on the streets
from 11 to 11 45 AM London looked to
anyone paying attention like it had been
dismembered and sewn back together with
a Glasgow smile and things wriggling
under the skin even I will not describe
what they did to the queen nobody
remembers it of course and the only
camera that captured it was an old
betamax camcorder yes we have the tape
it's a taste of what would have happened
if we had not acted quickly or
effectively or if we hadn't been
assisted
three we had help we had a lot of it for
one the fifth church was covering up its
own actions for us especially once its
focus shifted from remaking the world to
damage control and PR Integrity they
don't know how they managed to keep
basically everyone from discussing the
actual contents of scp-1425 chalk it up
to mind control know how they kept the
memories out of the heads of any
eyewitnesses including Studio audiences
choke it up to reality bending I suppose
but their secrecy did half our work for
us
that covers a lot of messy business most
of it was taken out in case the fifth
Church got their hands on the
information but I'm getting ahead of
myself one such point is the full
cooperation of the FCC and ofcom in
allowing us to kill broadcasts whenever
we required the favor we did to make
them always like that is beyond even my
cleanse
four it wasn't enough protocol of fire
kiss spookiest of all spook shows was a
massive expenditure of resources which
did a lot of good but it wasn't a
complete success our expert procedures
for voiding star signals in the public
Consciousness primary among them being
the expectation that the cover story
would be swallowed and society's
attention would move on left certain
gaps behind to say the least on all the
points in the protocol was a certain SCP
object which was to be used only if
absolutely necessary and we used it
we're still dealing with the
consequences of activating project lathe
but I do not regret the decision
sometimes you have to cut deeper into a
wound to clean the infection
5. the eid's lucky number apparently we
were betrayed the investigation carried
out in the England side song covered the
reason out of Ficus was less effective
there fittest infiltration and all the
secrets of the church leaking acolytes
under our radar for a year maybe longer
needless to say we purge the English
sites of any moles so quickly that I
didn't make your head spin that is
unless you're the Southern fifthist and
it does that already
I'll leave you with a warning command
stance on the topic is that the sleepers
have been eradicated but it is my belief
that the operation was not local if at
any point you detect a whiff of [ __ ]
or smoke for that matter tell your
director hell tell me and if you're a
fifthist yourself and you're reading it
I can only congratulate you on your
success but I should ask does the phrase
a star a star mean anything to you
it does to me
make sure to ask your deacon
JL and Maya director Eid Liverpool 8 15
2006.
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
welcome to another episode of extra
credit today's episode is written by
Reddit user Rock D house so without
further Ado let's get into it today I'll
be providing an explanation of
scp-1425 also known as the book star
signals this is an extremely important
SCP on the site besides the 500 plus
rating it also introduced the fifth
Church a major group of interest and the
third major anomalous religion it has
spawned countless scps and Tails and so
much as I'll be explaining it I'll be
explaining in the religion that it found
it here we go the containment procedures
are relatively straightforward taking
into account the safe classification
it's shown that this book will just sit
there and do nothing if I left it alone
however the one Oddity is the excessive
secure Purity when it comes to accessing
it access to the document is to be
completely restricted barring Express
written permission of at least two of
the following officials the site
director the Eid Chief these CMA head or
o5 personnel
to get this document you have to get
permission from two highly ranked
individuals of the foundation whatever
information is contained in it is very
dangerous
did you know that some stars in the sky
are dead but we still see their ancient
image with the best-selling novel star
signals sold in four countries and
translated into hundreds of languages
you too can tune into the celestial
frequencies and then become like the
stars
this book appears to be based on the
kind of new age hippie mumbo-jumbo cult
religions that got popular in the 70s
focus on misunderstood Native American
imagery random misused scientific terms
Celestial frequencies side note the
astrophysics nerd in me can't help but
correct a misconception the first part
of the back cover seems like it refers
to the fact that due to the fact that
light takes time to arrive to Earth some
Stars we see are already dead but we
can't tell due to the delay however even
short-lived stars have million-year
lifespans and some of the oldest light
we get are only about a hundred years
old so either the authors of scp-1425
are slightly uneducated or they're
talking about other anomalous weirdness
either works
when a subject reads the full text of
scp-1425 the book exerts a mild reality
warping effect influenced by the
subject's desires which in turn are
influenced by scp-1425 see below when a
sufficiently large number of subjects
are exposed to this effect further
complications arise in terms of mental
health and the Integrity of space-time
here's the danger reading it gives you
superpowers sort of but it also damages
you mentally and causes General wear and
tear of the fabric of space-time we take
a break from this to get some other
miscellaneous facts about the book but
based on weird things like tuning into
star frequencies and not actually doing
anything productive and that it contains
a lot of memetic cues memetic things are
specific words and phrases that can
abnormally alter your brain far more
than actual memories most of these serve
to make people concentrate on the same
thing at the same time and homogenize
their personalities it also causes
something called Ojai syndrome
scp-1425 is believed to have been
written and published by operatives of
the fifth Church an influential cult
whose membership consists largely of
celebrities including actors musicians
authors television hosts and other
personalities
here we get a little hint that the fifth
Church isn't based on any weird New Age
cult but one in particular Scientology
for those unfamiliar Scientology is
based on the works of elrond Hubbard who
hated psychologists and wrote some bad
sci-fi the religion is as weird as that
makes it sound and it got really popular
in Hollywood with a lot of actors I'll
be bringing up the parallels throughout
this article
these connections were utilized by the
fittest Fellowship in the form of
celebrity endorsements and widespread
media coverage used to make scp-1425
quickly and exceptionally popular due to
these measures as well as substantial
Word of Mouth advertising star signals
became a national bestseller within two
weeks of publication and held this
position until the book was virtually
purged from public knowledge by the SCP
Foundation using protocol of ficus
so this is the main story of scp-1425 it
was released these prominent celebrities
advertised it it got popular and when
the foundation realized its effects its
existence was erased the next section
deals with excerpts I'm going to be
mostly skipping over this section as
there's not much to be learned from each
individual section but to summarize it
shows the general language the fifthists
use the instructor is both similar to
self-help books and religious preaching
but there's a generous helping of dream
logic thrown on top you get sentences
that start normally but bring in strange
Concepts that don't have any context for
example
you can feel it inside you right now a
heavy emptiness in the middle of your
chest it's a reflection of the one in
your existence like particles in quantum
entanglement
besides learning about what fitheists
sound like a lot of recurring fittest
imagery is introduced now most of these
are explored in later scps so I'm not
going to explain them all but a quick
list stars and star signals fifthists
like to focus on energy emanating from
the stars and focusing on Space the
number five this number appears a lot
often counterpointed with other numbers
submission to the flow fifthists don't
like individuality or personal will
smoke fifthists either follow it or emit
it from themselves archons higher beings
seen with fear and or awe although it's
bad if you hate them because it draws
attention to yourself possibly a
representation of
scp-3125 it is also important to note
that the dream logic and the memetic
triggers become far more common as the
book progresses eventually degrading
into the fifthist language a continent
heavy speech that signifies the speaker
is heavily affected by Massive mimetics
then we get to the main meat of the
article the report of the emergence of
scp-1425 so after it's released on day
one day eight a celebrity promotion of
the book gets really controversial after
the host swears presumably being
affected by the mimetics as there was no
real prompt or any a reason to say [ __ ]
it's finding holes similarly to fifthism
Scientology first entered the public eye
through celebrity mentions and not
exactly in a planned way those around
may remember 2008 with Tom Cruise's
video linked to the internet in what was
supposed to be an internal training
video he talks about some of the more
crazy and obscure aspects of
scientologists beliefs although the
organization was infamously known before
this incident it sparked interest again
and led to the Scientology Anonymous war
of 08 but that's another story anyway we
get a description of the Ojai syndrome
mentioned earlier on day 12 a family in
Ojai start talking in the dreamlogic
speech and the fifthist speech and also
cunning up bystanders basically it's
what happens when readers of scp-1425
are overcome by the massive amount of
memetics this points the foundation at
1425 as a a possible SCP so they begin
studying it on day 13. they figure out
its anomalous properties and realize
that based on its strict reading regimen
and using the day 8 popularity boost as
a starting point there will be a spike
in Ojai sufferers on day 19.
day 14 the foundation kicks into high
gear bringing on additional agencies to
suppress information and burn as many
1425s as possible further action
redacted is the first hint that the
foundation is really pulling the big
guns guns beyond your security clearance
meanwhile celebrities keep going insane
some politicians talk about machine
elves The Usual by day 17 the foundation
is moderately getting a handle on things
the majority of Ojai sufferers have been
treated Class B amnestics work well with
this as they make you forget it appears
that most of what remains are those who
got the book slightly earlier on so
they're more likely to avoid having
their copy of scp-1425 get taken away
in response the foundation begins to use
Force where fifthism has taken hold to
get rid of the books and cure members
some of the really weird effects start
showing on prominent public figures as
the host of American Idols start
emitting smoke from their mouths for
nearly the entirety of the episode
day 19 as predicted there are a lot of
affected people wandering the streets
trying to follow smoke an interesting
interview takes place where the subject
appears not to be there and the
interviewer is dragged off screen at the
end both are never found
scp-2456 suggests that they were erased
from memory and public perception but as
it's part of another SCP I won't be
explaining it here
after that the foundation does some
general cleanup as symptoms died down
they also start planning to take out the
fifth church then we get the director
note which does a lot of my job for me
by describing what lies between the line
he talks about how this was one of the
biggest and most dangerous containment
breaches in foundation's history and
they got lucky one thing mentioned is
that how the foundation was not as
effective in Britain in getting rid of
scp-1425 as day 20 the massive sufferers
pushed on reality hard enough to turn
London into the physical manifestation
of the dream logic or rather nightmare
Logic the reason for the cleanup failure
is another nod towards Scientology
infiltration in 1978 Scientology got
into really hot water after the FBI
uncovered their operations Snow White
where they systematically infiltrated
the US government Scientology used it
for tax evasion feathers used it to stop
the foundation from culling their ranks
overall though the director tells that
the only reason why it wasn't a complete
failure was because the fifth church was
actually working to stop scp-1425 from
spreading after a point it seems that
the members began to worry that all the
reality restructuring was giving them a
negative image so they used the control
they had to stop effects from discussing
the book in reviews and such Scientology
had a similar phase back in 08 when Tom
Cruise video was leaked their modus
operandi was to initially draw in people
through more sensible mantras like solve
your problems by separating them into
smaller segments over time then they
would introduce some of their more
radical ideas however by having such a
public figure talk about some of the
more late stage indoctrination material
it gave them a very bad image
Scientology censorship operation was
less successful than fifthists as the
Streisand Effect made it so their
attempts to take down the video earned
them more Flack I just love how close
this parallels late stage material gets
released video reality warping
organization would rather their face to
the uninitiated be the more mild intro
stuff and so they try to take it down
anyway the director tells that in order
to get the situation under control they
had to utilize an SCP object with very
negative consequences the director
assures us that this was better than the
alternative of widespread fifth is
conversion the log ends with a message
to any potential remaining fifthist
infiltrators a star a star although it's
never explained context makes me think
there's some sort of memetic trigger
designed only to work against those in
the fifth church or the director is a
member of the fifth Church who knows so
to summarize this summary of scp-1425
it's a book that allows you you to
banned reality but it also makes you
insane it was published by a
representation of Scientology where all
the crazy things they believe is made
real since public figures are
disproportionately affected due to this
group the foundation does everything
they can to wipe an entire month's worth
of cultural memories anyway that's
scp-1425 the one that started the whole
group of Interest again I would like to
thank Reddit user Rock D house for this
explanation links will be in the
description
thank you for listening if indeed indeed
you still are and you're all dismissed
again see you in the next one
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
Timothy
zargaron
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
vinu
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crop guy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you